in this lecture we will explore some
classic puzzles
many of which have been driving people
crazy for centuries
on the surface they seem very different
sliding blocks
jumping pegs and blinking lights but
they do have some common features
and i'll mention one of them here
although none of these are what you'd
call
number puzzles we'll see that each of
them deals with
odd and even numbers in their solution
or analysis
i thought of calling this lecture odd
puzzles can be
even more interesting but i changed my
mind now let's get started
let's begin with a classic puzzle you
might even call it the rubik's cube
of the 19th century it's called the 15
puzzle and i'm sure you've seen one of
these before in some form or another
sometimes there's a picture that gets
scrambled up in which you have to
restore the picture
in its classic form you have the numbers
1 through 15
and a 4 by 4 square and a blank space
that allows the squares
to move now here's an electronic version
that works on the ipad you start with a
randomly scrambled position and your
goal is to get it back to the original
order
i'll say more about the mathematics and
history of the puzzle later
but let me first teach you how to solve
the puzzle
the solution is pretty intuitive you
basically get the numbers in the right
place
one at a time with just an occasional
twist
let me first outline the solution method
for you and then we'll solve a random
puzzle
starting from a random position you
first want to move the tiles
one and two to their goal positions
that's pretty easy next you want to
bring
three and four to their positions but if
you bring the three
here then you probably aren't going to
be able to get the 4
into its proper place so instead
you bring the 3 here and
the blank here right so you have the 3
here the four here
and the blank here after that we can
bring
the three and four to their proper
places
like so the numbers one through four
are now in their final positions and
they won't move
for the rest of the puzzle the next row
is pretty much the same
first you bring the 5 and 6 to their
proper positions
then bring the 7 over here and the 8
over there with a blank over here and
then you bring them home
like so the first two rows are finished
and you'll never need to touch them
again now we're starting to run out of
maneuvering room
the next tiles we place are not 9 and
10 but 9 and 13.
we want to bring them here but if we
start by putting the 9
there we won't be able to squeeze the 13
into the corner so first bring the 9
and 13 next to each other like so
then bring them home
almost done next we want to move the 10
and 14 to their final positions
but to do that we first need to bring
them here
and then to here finally we're just left
with the 11
12 and 15 in some order
if the original puzzle was solvable then
they can simply be
rotated to reach the goal position
like so
world chess champion bobby fisher was
able to do this puzzle consistently
in under 25 seconds i'm happy if i can
finish it
in under two minutes so let's give it a
try
okay here we go i'll talk through it as
i do the problem okay one is already in
the right position so i first have to
bring
the two over like so
okay next we want to bring the three
and the four over to there okay the
three is where where it needs to be
now let's get the four underneath it
like so three four
are done okay now let's move that five
up where it wants to go
okay well we got to get the 6 next to it
all right let's take the long way to get
there all right now
okay there we are oh the 7's where where
it needs to be that's great let's put
the 8 underneath it now we have 7 and 8.
now we need to get 9 and 13 next to each
other there they are
we can now slide them to where they
belong good finally we need to get the
10
and the 14 next to
each other let's space them out here
first and now we can put the
10 and 14 like so great 11 12 15.
we're done hey i broke one minute that's
a personal best
the 15 puzzle was invented by noyes
chapman a postmaster from new york and
later popularized by the puzzle maker
sam
lloyd lloyd offered a thousand dollars
to anyone who could solve the following
puzzle
starting from the original 15 puzzle
position
can you rearrange the tiles to reach
this position where tiles 14
and 15 have been swapped
lloyd's money was safe because it turns
out that this puzzle
has no solution the reason has to do
with
even and odd numbers let me explain
the numbers one two and three can be
arranged
in six ways right three factorial ways
let's look at the arrangement one three
two so i have the cups here one two
three let's look at the arrangement
one three two like so notice that we can
bring it back to the original order by
performing
one swap right i go from one three two
to one two three in one swap whereas if
i started with the arrangement
2 3 1 then that's going to require
two swaps like i could swap the 1 and
the 2
then the 2 and the 3 like so
here's a table of all 6 arrangements
mathematicians call these permutations
along with the number of swaps needed to
bring them back to the original order
here they are now let's look at one
three two again okay now there are
a lot of other ways we can use swaps to
bring it back to the original order
right so like for instance i could go oh
i could swap do one move here
and then another move here and then
finally another swap here
okay that took me three swaps
now there are other sequences of moves
that take three swaps
or five swaps or seven swaps
what's interesting or should i say
what's odd is that
no matter how hard you try you can't
straighten out one three two
in an even number of swaps
the number of swaps has to be an
odd number so we call one
three two an odd arrangement
looking at all six arrangements again we
can label them
as odd or even as follows
notice half of them are even half of
them are odd
so just like every number can be labeled
as
odd or even every arrangement of objects
whether it be three objects 16 objects
or whatever
can be labeled as odd or even
so to bring your arrangement back to its
original order
an odd arrangement requires an odd
number of swaps
and an even arrangement requires an even
number of swaps
so let's go back to the 15 puzzle
okay here's a brand new arrangement
every position
is some arrangement of 16 objects right
namely the numbers 1 through 15 and the
blank
now lloyd's puzzle is clearly an
odd arrangement since it's just one
swap away from the original order right
just swapping 14 and 15
gives you lloyd's arrangement so that's
clearly an odd arrangement
because one is an odd number so if
there's a solution to lloyd's puzzle
using legal moves
it must be an odd number of legal moves
but notice this every legal move
is actually a swap that involves the
blank square
and an adjacent square right if i move
as i'm moving this
you can really think of every move as
a swap with the blank tile and
some other tile but notice that the
blank square
begins in the lower right corner
and it ends in the lower right
corner thus the blank square
must travel an equal number of moves to
the left
as moves to the right and the blank
square has to make an equal number of
up moves as down moves so the total
number of
moves all of which are swaps must be
an even number so in order for a puzzle
to be
solvable it has to come from an
even arrangement thus lloyd's problem
here is
impossible since it came from an odd
arrangement now as it turns out
we can solve any position that comes
from an even arrangement
of the numbers 1 through 15. so for
example
if we swap 14 and 15
and also say 4 and 9
then the algorithm we learned will
successfully solve it
but if we start from any odd position
then our
process then our process would
eventually lead us to the lloyd position
and we would be stuck now we saw
earlier with the arrangement of three
numbers that
half the arrangements were odd and half
of them
were even and that's true in general so
if someone
physically removed the tiles of a 15
puzzle okay just
shook them out here and put them back at
random
then there would only be a 50
chance that the puzzle would be solvable
in fact when i was preparing for the
course one of the apps that i
purchased had that very flaw
half the time the puzzle it gives you is
unsolvable how frustrating
some apps like the one we use here from
the company app
annex are smarter and only give you
solvable puzzles by the way
how can you tell if a given arrangement
of pieces
will be solvable or not after moving the
blank square to the bottom right hand
corner you can determine if an
arrangement is
even or odd by counting
for each square how many lower numbered
squares come after it
if it has an odd number of smaller
numbers that come
after it we call that square an oddball
at least i do a legal arrangement
has to have an even number
of oddballs so in the goal arrangement
there are no oddballs it's never the
case that a
lower number comes later than an earlier
number
there and so since 0 is an even number
then that's fine this is a legal
arrangement of course
whereas with the lloyd arrangement we
have
one oddball namely the number 15.
so this arrangement's impossible right
because after 15 comes 14
that's one number that's smaller than it
here's a random position from my app
now the number 12 has all
11 of its smaller numbers coming after
it right
so that makes 12 an oddball
right whereas let's look at the number
six in the diagram here
what numbers come after it 11 3 4 and
14.
3 and 4 are smaller than 6 so
6 has an even number of smaller numbers
coming after it
so 6 is not an oddball the number 10
has 7 of its smaller numbers coming
after it
so it's an oddball too you can check for
yourself that
none of the other numbers are oddballs
since this puzzle has exactly two
oddballs
it is solvable but if we swapped
any two of those numbers then we would
have
an unsolvable puzzle now in the 15
puzzle
you could tell that you were making good
progress towards a solution
as more and more of the squares were
brought to their proper place
but that's not always the case with
puzzles especially electronic ones like
we have in our next
example
i have here a three by three box of
lights at the start of the game some of
the lights are on
and some of the lights are off actually
these lights are all buttons and we can
label the buttons as numbered one two
three
four five six seven eight nine so
this position here you could say has
buttons that are lit
buttons two three five and eight those
are on
and the rest are off your goal is to
turn
off all the lights by pressing the right
combination of buttons
now there are three types of buttons
corner buttons
buttons one three seven and nine edge
buttons
two four six and eight and the middle
button
button five pressing a corner button
will toggle the corner and the three
surrounding lights
for example pressing button one will
toggle
these four lights the lights in cells
one
two four and five notice right now
we have off off on on well after i press
button one
it's going to look like on on off off
and if i press button one again it's
going to bring us back
to the original position whereas
pressing button
three toggles lights two three five and
six
pressing button seven will toggle these
four lights
and button nine will toggle those four
lights
like so pressing an edge button
will toggle the edge and two of its
surrounding neighbors
for example pressing button two up here
will toggle the lights and cells one
two and three so right now the first row
looks like off on
on then after pressing button two
it looks like on off off the other rows
don't change
okay pressing button two again would
take us back
to where we were similarly button
4 toggles lights 1 4 and 7. so these
lights get toggled
right now they're all off and then after
i press button 4
they're all on pressing four again
brings us back
and similar rules apply for pressing
button six
which toggles these three lights and
pressing button eight
which toggles those three lights
finally pressing button five the middle
button
toggles the middle and the four edge
lights
two four six and eight so pressing five
would take us from here
to there and back again
so those are the rules our goal is to
press
a sequence of buttons so we go from the
initial position
to the pitch to the position where all
lights are
out poof hopefully using as few buttons
as possible
the solution is far from obvious before
i give it to you
let me ask you another question when
pressing the buttons let's go back to
our
original position does the order
matter for example if i take a position
like this one
and press the buttons 1 2 3 4 in that
order will i get the same position
if i press the buttons in a different
order say 2 2-4-1-3
what do you think same or different
outcome
the answer is not clear to clarify this
situation
it's time to introduce what
mathematicians call
mod 2 arithmetic with mod 2 arithmetic
there are just two numbers zero and one
for the most part addition works in the
usual way
zero plus zero is zero zero plus one is
one
one plus zero is one but one plus one
is not two since the number two
is not in our original number system we
only allow
zero and one as a result with mod two
arithmetic
we have one plus one equals zero
one way to make sense of mod two
arithmetic is to think of
zero as representing any even number
and one is representing any odd number
then the mod 2 addition table is really
just saying
even plus even is even even plus odd is
odd
and odd plus odd is even let's see how
mod 2 arithmetic comes in handy with
this puzzle
first of all every position can be
represented by a
vector of zeros and ones where zero
means that a light is off
and one means that a light is on for
example our
beginning position here would have
vector representation
0 1 1 0 1 0
0 1 0 where we have a 1 in positions
2 3 5 and eight
now each button can also be represented
by
a vector for example pressing button two
which toggles the lights in positions
one two and three right pressing button
two
affects lights one two and three
i claim that pressing button two is just
like adding the vector
v two which consists of one one one
zero zero zero zero zero zero okay so
let's see that in action
for example if we take our beginning
position and press button
2 we get a new position where lights
1 5 and 8 are on
notice if we take the vector
representing the original position
with lights with with ones in positions
two three five and eight
and i add the vector v2 which has ones
in positions
one two and three and i do that addition
mod two of course
then the new vector b plus v2
will have ones in positions 1 5 and 8
just like our lights we have lights in
the first fifth and eighth
position similarly
pressing button one which toggles lights
one
two four and five is equivalent to
adding the vector v1
with ones in the first second fourth and
fifth position
and similarly for the other buttons by
the way
we've seen that pressing a button twice
in a row
leaves a position unchanged right but we
can also see that from vectors
for instance if we press button one
twice
that's just like adding the vector v1
plus v1
which is the vector of all zeros so
pressing a button twice in a row
literally adds nothing to your position
so now that you see that pressing a
button is the same as
adding adding one of the nine vectors v1
through v9
i'll ask you again does the order
that you press the buttons matter
for instance if you press button 1 then
button
2 is that the same as pressing 2
then 1. well pressing 1 then
2 is the same as adding the vector v1
plus v2 but notice that's the same
as adding v2 plus v1
so what that tells us is the order
doesn't
matter and that's true for any two
buttons
this fact was not at all obvious at
least to me
until we used vectors to represent the
buttons
all right so let's hear it for vectors
and mod 2 math
and by the way since order doesn't
matter
no solution would require you to press
the same button
twice right i mean never press a button
twice in a row you wouldn't have to do
it
so you wouldn't press them far apart
either because you could
rearrange those button presses so that
they were twice in a row
so in other words if a puzzle has a
solution
then it has a solution where every
button is
pressed at most once okay
but how do we find a solution
strictly speaking this is a problem from
linear algebra
the mathematics of vector equations
starting from your beginning position
represented by the vector b
you need to add some of the vectors v
1 through v 9 to reach the vector
of all zeros the vector of all zeros
is the position where all lights are off
now a linear algebra student can take
the initial vector
and the button vectors and find a unique
solution
by solving a system of equations but let
me show you
a quick way to solve this problem in
your head
without the need to write down a single
equation
recall that when we solve this puzzle
the order that you press the buttons
does not matter so since it doesn't
matter
i will always solve the puzzle in the
following
order i will first decide on the edge
buttons
then i'll decide the corner buttons
and then finally i'll decide the middle
button
now you'll admit that if i can do steps
one
and two correctly then the third step
deciding on the middle button
is trivial since i'll either be done
with the puzzle
or i'll have to press button five for
instance in the original puzzle here
once i choose the correct edge and
corner buttons
bam bam bam all the lights are off
and there's nothing left to do if the
lights were not out here let me press
button five
then we'd be in this position and we'd
only have to press button five to finish
like so but how do we decide the edges
and corners
okay let's look at the corners now i
claim that
if i can solve the edges then the
corners
are also easy extremely easy
here's why after i press the correct
edge buttons
the only buttons remaining for
consideration
are one three five seven and nine
now let's look at corner number one here
which of the remaining buttons will
affect
light one now button one will definitely
toggle it
but none of the remaining buttons will
right button three doesn't affect that
number five doesn't affect it seven and
nine
none of those affected so if light
one is on then you're going to have to
turn it
off right because in the end we want
everything off
so if it's off leave it alone
if it's on you must press it now the
same is true for the other corners
so in step two you simply turn off the
lights
at every corner so in the original
position
once i correctly choose the edge buttons
bam
bam then the corners are easy
the only lit corner is corner seven so
when we press it
we're done so if we can figure out the
edge buttons
then we're home free but how do we
figure
out the edge buttons for example how do
we decide whether or not to press
button two to do this
we look at the rectangle surrounding
button two now consider the following
question
for each of the buttons 1 through 9
how many lights are toggled inside the
rectangle
i've written the answer for each button
here
for example button one toggles
these four lights all of which are in
the rectangle
button five toggles five lights but only
four of them are in the rectangle that's
why we have a four there
button eight toggles three lights but
none of them are in the rectangle that's
why the zero's there
now do you notice anything interesting
about button
two it toggles three
lights inside the rectangle and it's the
only button
that toggles an odd number
in the end we want no lights on in that
rectangle
so here's what we do count the lights
in the rectangle surrounding button two
we see that in in our position here that
there are
presently three buttons lit inside of
that rectangle right
that's an odd number in the end we need
to have an
even number we need to have zero lights
lit
in that rectangle so since all the other
buttons
will change the number of lights in that
rectangle
by an even amount if we want to get from
an
odd number of lights in that rectangle
to an even number of lights in that
rectangle
we must press button to now
the other edge buttons can be determined
in a similar way
for example with button 4 we look at the
rectangle that surrounds
it and see that right now it has
three lights lit inside of that
rectangle
since we want to have an even number
we're going to have to press
button 4 to change the parity of its
rectangle
from odd to even on the other hand when
i look at the rectangle for
for button 6 we see that it has four
lights lit that's an even number so we
leave button six
alone how about button eight tell me
what we should do here for
eight eights rectangle has two lights
lit
right that's an even number so do we
press it
or leave it alone it's even so we'll
leave it alone
so which of the which of the four edge
buttons are we gonna press
buttons two and four let me do so
quickly
bam bam all right all that we're left
is pressing button seven and
we're done let's do one more example
okay create a random position that looks
nice
how do we do this first we're going to
decide the edge buttons then we'll do
the corner buttons
and then we'll do the middle buttons to
do the edge buttons we have to look at
the rectangles for buttons 2
4 6 and 8. button 2 has a rectangle that
looks like this
and i see it has four lights lit so
we're gonna leave button two alone
uh rectangle four has four lights lit
okay we'll leave that one alone the
rectangle for button six
has three lights lit so we're gonna want
to press six
and the rectangle for button eight has
four lights lit
so we're gonna leave that one alone so
the only edge button we need to press
is button six so let's do that
okay next we press the corners
that are lit i only have two lit corners
we'll do that
bam bam well we're not done yet so that
means we have to press the middle button
when we do that we're done
the last puzzle i'd like to do was a
favorite of mine of my childhood
called peg solitaire it's typically
played on a board that looks like a
giant plus sign
every spot except for the central one is
occupied by a peg
or sometimes a marble pieces can jump
over other pieces horizontally or
vertically
provided there's an empty space on the
other side
and the piece that's jumped over is
removed from the board
for example in this puzzle our first
move can either be a horizontal jump
like this or it could be a vertical jump
like that
the goal of the puzzle is to jump your
pieces in such a way
that all you're left with at the end is
one
piece preferably in the middle of the
board
in fact one puzzle maker says that if
you can end up with one piece
you are outstanding and if it's in the
middle of the board
then you are a genius let me first show
you a quick solution to this puzzle
then i'll show you that contrary to the
puzzle maker's claim
ending up with one peg outside the
middle hole
should not make you outstanding okay
here's the solution to the puzzle begin
by making our initial move
towards the center or as i like to say
bottoms
up now here's the mnemonic i use
to clear most of the pegs from the board
as a professor you write lots of papers
especially early in your career as you
seek tenure
and promotions and no matter how many
papers you've written
it seems that there's always one more
right up left
if you want to move up in the profession
so repeat after me right up left then
move it up okay and we're gonna repeat
this
four times so we go right
up left
and then move it up it is this peg here
how do we move it up
by bringing this down and jumping up all
right if you didn't get it that's okay
we're going to do it three more times
i rotate the board and one more time we
go
right up
left and move it
up just like so
all right we rotate again
right up left
and move it up
okay last chance rotate
and we have right up
left and move it
up and when we do and i'll rotate it one
last time
we have a house right or
a space invaders character whatever
whatever you'd like
now we're going to clear the rest of the
pegs by going to the attic in the house
and this piece is going to do a grand
tour
all around and annihilate most of the
pegs here we go
we we're going to jump here and then
here
and then here and then here
and then here and then here
ending up in this t formation and now
the puzzle's pretty easy to solve right
we jump
this way that way
this way and we're
done got it you are now
officially a genius curiously
as we're about to see the middle square
is practically the only place that a
single peg can end
up i'll prove it to you by labeling our
board with the symbols
x y and z like so
now i'm going to give you some simple
rules for adding the symbols
x y and z together and you'll see why we
want to do this
in a minute now here's my addition
table take a look at it notice that when
when we add
two letters together we get the third
one
for for instance x plus y equals z
or z plus x equals y
when you add a symbol to itself you get
zero for instance x plus x is zero
and as usual adding zero to something
leaves it unchanged
for instance zero plus y is y
now what do x y and z represent when we
did
mod 2 arithmetic we saw that 0
and 1 could be thought of as even and
odd numbers with x y z arithmetic
we think of each symbol as representing
a pair
of even or odd numbers here x would be
the even odd pair
y is odd even z is odd odd
and 0 is even even then
everything is nice and consistent for
example the statement
x plus y equals z really says
even odd plus odd even equals
odd odd which makes sense right for
instance
2 1 plus five two equals
seven three and a statement like x
plus x equals zero is saying that
even odd plus even odd is
even even anyway trust me when i say
that the symbols
x y z and zero form a consistent
mathematical system called the klein
four group
i'll point out one last useful fact i
claim that
x plus y plus z is zero we can verify
this because
x plus y plus z is the same as
z plus z which is zero
okay so how do these symbols help us
understand peg solitaire for any peg
solitaire position we define its
signature to be the sum of the symbols
of all of the occupied squares
for example the t formation that we saw
earlier
has signature x plus y plus z
plus x plus z that's zero
plus y which is y
okay how about the house position
exploiting the fact that x plus y plus z
is zero
i see a three x y z triples each of
which sums to zero so we could ignore
those
so the signature here is x plus
z which is y what about the signature of
the original position
if we replace each xyz with 0
we get massive cancellation and all that
we're left with
is x plus z which is y
hm it seems as if every position
has a signature of y do you see
why look at the x y z pattern
on the board okay this one here notice
that
every three consecutive squares
contains an x and a y
and a z like say in this position here
or here or there
every time you perform a jump you're
replacing
two pegs from occupied squares
with one peg from an unoccupied square
for instance if you jump from x over
z you must land on a y
but that won't change the signature at
all
since x plus z is equal to
y consequently the signature of the
board
will never change and since the
signature
started at y it will forever
be y thus if we can reduce the puzzle
down to a single peg then it must be on
a square
with label y
and yet not every square with a y
is a possible ending point for a single
peg
now why is that for example i claim that
we cannot
[ __ ] we cannot wind up with a single peg
on this square now why is that because
if we could if there was a sequence of
moves
that where a peg ended up on that square
then by symmetry we could also have
performed a sequence of moves that would
allow a single peg to finish
on this square and since it's impossible
for a single peg to finish on a z square
we can't finish on that y square
either by the same logic you can
disqualify
most of the other y squares as landing
spots
except for these five and yet
how could the final peg land in one of
these
end squares how could we get something
to end up in this square
only if the last two pegs were situated
like this
but if that's the case then those pegs
could have just as easily jumped
to the center and if getting to a peg in
the center
earns you a genius rating you'd be
foolish to jump the peg anywhere else
so why should a solution of one peg away
from the middle
earn you an outstanding rating i don't
know
a couple of years ago i was at a
friend's house and i noticed a puzzle he
had in his living room
that he that he had picked up in his
travels it looked like peg solitaire but
it had
four extra squares on it just like in
the original puzzle
all the squares were occupied except for
the middle square
my friend said that he was never able to
solve the puzzle
then he said hey you're a mathematician
maybe you can figure it out i brought
out a piece of paper
and labeled the board with x's y's and
z's
just like before with the four new
squares included
let's see why my friend was having such
trouble
it was still the case that every three
consecutive
squares in a row or column had an x
a y and a z in it so the signature would
not
change so what is the new signature
well previously the signature was y
so the new signature which has these
four new squares on it
would be y plus x plus y
plus z plus y and since y plus y
is zero and x plus y plus z is 0
the signature of the new board is simply
0. consequently it would be
impossible for a single peg to land
anywhere since that would change the
signature
to x or y or z
hence the puzzle was impossible my
friend was grateful
and my reputation was saved
in this lecture we've seen how
mathematics plays an interesting role
in solving and understanding various
puzzles
although the puzzles we considered were
very different their solution methods
had some common elements which apply to
many other puzzles as well
one thing to look for when solving a
puzzle is what computer scientists
sometimes call
a macro a macro takes rules of your game
and looks for efficient combinations of
those moves
that help you solve your problem in the
15
puzzle once we found an efficient way to
solve the top row
we could repeat that process for the
second row
and the last two rows were finished in a
similar fashion
and in peg solitaire we found that the
right
up left and move it up macro could be
performed four
times and reduce our puzzle to a much
more tractable problem
another common theme that appeared in
all of our puzzles
was the exploitation of parity
now for instance in the 15 puzzle we saw
that there were
odd arrangements and even arrangements
the analysis of our electronic game
was all about mod 2 arithmetic and even
with peg solitaire
we found that the symbols x y and z and
0
represented pairs of even or odd numbers
with games of chance we spoke often
about determining
the best odds and trying to break even
and so it is with puzzles that it often
pays
to look at odds and evens too
let me end with one last impossible
puzzle
frequently found in restaurants while
waiting for your pancakes
it's peg solitaire played on a
triangular board
like so starting with one
empty hole on the top your goal
is to eliminate all pegs but one
preferably left in the top hole
here's the solution along with my
mnemonics
now after our initial jump okay that is
from here to there the next four moves
we'll all use this point somehow
now after this sideways jump
my daughter said that this sort of looks
like a snail
hmm okay so now the snail
will lose its tail on the pail
all right what do i mean by that all
right so the snail
loses its tail
on the pail
and now we aim for an a minus and i'll
tell you what i mean by that in a moment
by jumping from the corner followed by a
double jump
so i jump here and a double jump
jump jump and now i have an
a minus the top two
all right now finally we create a
diamond
by jumping up from here
up from there and now we clear the rest
one two three and we are done
time for some pancakes
in our next lecture we'll take on
perhaps the most famous puzzle of all
time
so be there or be square or maybe i
should say
be there and be cute
[Music]
you